amazon are negotiating really hard to
get the mgm sale finalized as quickly as
possible and where are we with the new
stargate series
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
i did a video a couple of days ago about
how mgm negotiating really really hard
with the regulators and one of the
things they've agreed is that all of
their major productions in the future
through mgm will be made within the
united states
so where are we right now
first of all i'm going to go back to
the giant freaking robot story from over
a year ago that a lot of people have
repeated that actually mgm were planning
to do two tv series
a live action series probably the brad
wright project and an animated series
now i did that video and then i got a
message from a certain person that works
not directly for mgm but a company um
linked to mgm that does a lot of legal
work for them and he's actually um an
accountant
some information might have been changed
to protect his identity and he basically
said that this story was true six months
ago but it isn't anymore there's a new
executive in charge of scripted material
at mgm and he didn't like the animated
idea he basically said mgm don't have
the capability to produce a high quality
animated series anyway
they're also very aware that the last
time stargate did an animated series it
was terrible
so
he decided no animated project we're
going to focus on brad wright's
this source though also told me that
actually he never really believed that
this project was going to get off the
ground anyway the brad's rights project
was never actually going to get made
the point of that was to generate more
interest from amazon and to try to
generate more money for the sale because
mgm became aware very early on that
amazon are very very interested in
regenerating the stargate project
they want stargate on our tv screens as
quickly as possible
so what's more valuable than just a back
catalog
a project that's actually in development
so that's what they did they started
developing the tv show in the hope of
making more money and increasing
amazon's interest in the sale
now that doesn't mean it was never going
to happen but it was reasonably unlikely
when brad wright talks about kovitz
stopping production and then obviously
the sale going through and that really
put a damper on things i think that's
what he was hoping that would happen but
this project was never actually green
lit it was never actually in
pre-production it was just in
development i think that was just a ploy
by mgm a very clever ploy by mgm
to get amazon as interested as possible
now
this source then actually put me in
touch with a couple of other people
people that actually do work directly
for mgm and they are actually on the
creative side of things
now they are not high up executives or
anything but they obviously do hear
stories around the water cooler
they moved on and actually said that
yes the brad ride project was probably
never going to happen mainly because
when amazon sort of did get involved and
did see what was being planned they said
no no you must think a lot bigger they
actually want more from the stargate
series than what brad wright was
planning
so
they said immediately we want a movie we
want to kick things off with a film
they're looking at their back catalog
and thinking you know what the original
stargate movie is the 10th highest
grossing mgm
movie of all time
we've just done the tomorrow war and
that did really really well we want to
repeat that success and we think
stargate is the platform to do it that
would then spin off into
a tv series and possibly even an ancient
tv series a sort of a prequel series is
also being considered
now
the sale of mgm might [ __ ] that plan up
but i'm going to do another video and
it's basically it seems to be that
amazon has basically three plans and i'm
going to go through them in more detail
in another video but for now we can say
that that is their planet they would
like to do a movie that spins off into a
tv series
it is also though true that
conversations have been had with roland
emerick about doing a hard reboot of the
trilogy of stargate movies he originally
planned because the original plan for
stargate was that it would be a trilogy
of films
now you can go back and have a look at
my video on that and what i think about
that but basically
amazon don't consider that to be plan a
but they are considering it while things
are on a bit of a pause at the moment
and it is also true that when i spoke to
the people from mgm
that there is a feeling that amazon's
control over mgm is already pretty much
total it's already pretty much there
the top executives want to keep their
jobs in a few months when amazon take
over so they are even though amazon
can't dictate creative license to
mgm at the moment they don't own mgm
they can't tell mgm what to do the
people in charge are listening and they
are not going to do anything that would
jeopardize their very lucrative
contracts and very lucrative jobs in the
next few years
and a lot of people are very nervous
about what amazon are going to do with
stargate but let's look at the evidence
a little bit
the only real comparable project i can
think of is the expanse big sci-fi
production and it's been done really
really well amazon have actually looked
after that series i think beautifully
the first series was cancelled amazon
took it on they didn't mess around with
it they didn't sort of force their um
thing ideas onto the production company
they enter the executives in charge they
let them get on with it and they let
them then make another three series the
last series has just brought it was
excellent
um it's a project that's been sort of
lovingly looked after by amazon
i hope stargate will be the same thing
amazon's influence on mgm i'm sure will
be more financial because one of the
things they've actually said is they
would like stargate to be sort of along
the lines of the marvel model with a tv
series movies games and things that
actually intertwine with each other
there will be an idea of these phases um
of so so the movies the tv series the
games and other projects would sort of
have maybe one major bad guy or one sort
of focus to them and then when that
ended they would that would move on to
the next one so the series even though
you might have five or six series of the
tv series
they would have a focus over one or two
series then another different focus over
the next couple of series and so on and
so on
they also want the games the tv series
and the movies to influence each other
now that's really interesting point
because stargate timekeepers is about to
be released and back in the next few
months
when it is released i think it's going
to tell us a lot about what amazon are
planning but because if this idea about
these projects influence each other is
true then what happens in the game might
actually be very very relevant to what
happens in the tv series now i'm going
to say that there's one danger with that
the game is called timekeepers and
apparently it does jump between time
frames ancients sg-1 if we're going to
see elements from the different series
in fact
and possibly even into the future that
screams to me that they might be
thinking about doing a star trek kind of
soft reboot where they say this is in a
parallel universe or actually they time
travel and change things and so that
they can do whatever they want with the
new series
without having to maybe strictly stick
to canon
that worries me mainly because one it's
been done
two i think it's a bit lazy
and three
i don't want weird klingon thing going
on um you know they just they they made
the klingon so strange in star trek i
don't want a weird new goggle ruled
thing um i would like that i would
basically like what happened in sg1 and
sgu and sg atlantis to stay canon and
for not to mess with it and i would like
a continuation of the story i have done
a video where i talked about how maybe a
hard reboot is the way to go and i can
kind of understand the thinking for it
but it's not what i want
i don't want roland denrick and dean
devlin to make their
trilogy and movies i want a new series
and a new set of movies
that
that respect what was done before
so that's where we're at right now we're
in a holding pattern and that's the
truth anybody that says they know
definitely 100 what's going to happen
with stargate or any other mgm project
in the future is not telling the truth
but it is true that amazon considers
stargate to be a really important
project for the future they've called it
the sleep and giant of sci-fi and let's
be honest it really is you only have to
look at the how much people talk about
it on social media and on facebook and
everything else how many videos like
this come out and how many hits i get on
videos that do by stargate to see that
it's very very interesting to people
they love this show and want it to come
back and amazon know that that means
cha-ching and money
so that's where we're at please leave a
comment tell me what you think
what is going on amazon and mgm and what
do you want to see in the new start game
please if you're new to the channel like
subscribe hit that bell notification
share the video wherever the hell you
like we're on facebook please go and
join i'm always sticking memes on there
and i want you to do the same um the
links in the description we're on
twitter as well
so i will get all the news out to you as
quickly as i possibly can
thanks for watching please stay safe and
i'll see you next time
[Music]